what's going on there reject nation g
and j
here today um so people were telling me
that uh stephen colbert did this bit
with uh zack snyder that aired
yesterday where like he directed a late
show
segment it was like a 10 minute thing
and i was like guys i can't react to
this because
we've had videos in the past that were
like colbert clips were featured as part
of like
a montage or something and that stuff
just got the whole video blocked
worldwide but then this little isolated
clip got sent our way
and i'm hoping we can get away who's
watching it
and showing our reaction to you guys
because when i saw the title it was
zack snyder says suck at warner brothers
and i was like
what he said
oh man yeah it's only like 30 seconds
out of the 10 minute
bit like i said there's a reason why we
can't do a reaction to the whole thing
but i figured this must be the main the
money more than the money the money
yeah so let's let's see what he
said exactly
[Music]
the whole episode is 16 hours and 47
minutes and that's just the beginning
of the extended late show snyder verse
we're talking spin-offs
animated specials theme park rides
suck it warner brothers socket
uh wow uh his words not mine
but uh yeah second warner brothers
goodness i mean sometimes you gotta
watch the whole thing in this entire
context
yeah i heard about what this bit is i
haven't seen any of it it's the only
thing that's in
zack snyder is talking to the the
interviewer
he's like yo his words not mine but suck
it
warner brothers but also my way
let me throw down on that because he's
been very
vocal lately like way more transparent
than
ever it felt like leading up to zack
snyder's justice league release
you know he was saying some stuff and
being like honest about things
but it seems like ever since the the
post release of that movie
he's been brutally honest about
his experience with warner brothers and
how one of the brothers use him and his
relationship all that stuff
so even though this is done in the form
of a satirical
sketch format where zack snyder's
directing
a late show with stephen colbert's
segment
i bet there's a bit of a cathartic
release that he gets to look at the
camera
absolutely sucking warrior brothers well
i bet
partly too now they're being sold off
and merged again you know it's probably
even more emboldening for somebody in
his position to be like hey i mean
i'm not gonna know any of the leadership
hit the new wb so hey
all bets are off oh man that was
hilarious
yeah good for you come full circle yeah
i'm sure you needed that zach
that's hilarious well that's it for
today guys
i'm glad we gotta watch that we gotta
wrap up a couple things for uh patreon
really quick and then
we got a jet 45 minutes away to go to a
special screening of a quiet place
too uh so yeah thank you guys for being
here
uh well let's see what else comes out
this weekend
goodbye oh let's check out our army of
the dead movie reaction